From "Poker Face" to "Joker Face"! Lady
Gaga gave her Little Monsters a sneak peek
of her Harley Quinn in the upcoming "Joker"
sequel, and the reaction was fantabulous.
Harley Quinn is easily one of the most dynamic
characters in DC's extensive roster of heroes and
baddies, and plenty of stars have taken a crack at
playing the unstable and heavily armed villainess.
"Don't worry, I'm over the crime thing, see?"
Margot Robbie notably debuted her
portrayal of Dr. Harleen Quinzel
in 2016's "Suicide Squad." She later
reprised the role in both "Birds of
Prey" and James Gunn's half-sequel,
half-do-over, "The Suicide Squad."
"You're a hero to me, as well as to my
people." "I think you might got me confused."
At the same time, Kaley Cuoco
began voicing an animated version
of the character in 2019 for the
"Harley Quinn" TV series. Now,
Lady Gaga is stepping up to the plate to play
Quinn in Todd Phillips' sequel to "Joker."
Starring Joaquin Phoenix in an Oscar-winning
performance as Arthur Fleck, "Joker" tracked
the origins of how a wannabe comedian became an
iconic supervillain. With its heady hallucinations
and choreographed dance sequences, "Joker" had
a bit of the spirit of Lady Gaga's stylized
and surreal brand of artistry. So it made
sense when the pop star took to Twitter in
August 2022 to confirm her involvement in the
upcoming sequel, titled "Joker: Folie à Deux".
With "Folie à Deux" set to be a musical,
Lady Gaga is arguably a top tier choice
to play its Harley Quinn. Even Margot
Robbie endorsed the casting decision,
noting that Quinn is an enduring
character, open to interpretation.
On February 14th, 2023, Gaga tweeted out a
first-look preview image of herself as Quinn.
In it, Gaga's character is staring
awestruck at Phoenix's Arthur with
some clown makeup smudged on her face, as she
clasps his head in her hands. Unsurprisingly,
no one is as excited to see Gaga morph
into the villain as her devoted fans.
Given the date of its release, Gaga's army
of Little Monsters received this photo as a
Valentine's Day treat, and needless
to say, fire emojis, heart emojis,
and gasps of "Mother!" were plentiful
in her Twitter replies. One fan posted,
"No trailer, No plot, No character
description. Just one Lady Gaga
shot on the 'Joker' set that has
everyone moving. That's impact."
Other users are even hoping that Gaga's
multi-hyphenate talents will earn her first Oscar
acting nomination since 2018's "A Star Is Born,"
cementing her status as a Hollywood powerhouse.
On Reddit too, among users of the
DC cinematic universe subreddit,
responses are largely positive to this first photo
of the pop superstar as Harley Quinn. For example,
in a thread dedicated to her
preview image, one user wrote,
"Lady Gaga can bring the weird energy,
so I think this should be pretty rad."
This comment alone received more than 600
upvotes. Similarly, another user argued that
good chemistry is already apparent
between Gaga and Joaquin Phoenix.
Meanwhile, users of a general pop
culture discussion subreddit are
likewise stoked about Gaga as Quinn.
One user posted about the image,
"I don't think I was sold on her as Harley until
this. Her whole face embodies the character wow,
I'm actually getting excited for this one now."
Fans will have to wait a little while longer
to see Gaga transform into Quinn on the big
screen, however. "Joker: Folie à Deux" is
scheduled for release on October 4, 2024.